I've grown my brand to over 10 million
subscribers across all platforms and in
this video I'm going to break down by
tier which of these platforms has the
highest potential for making you money
with my real up-to-date stats and where
I'm investing for the next year so let's
start with Tik Tok so if we're going to
analyze platforms based on how much
money-making potential they have inside
of them then these are the stats that I
care about first is who so who's on this
platform if there's a platform with tons
of kids on it versus people who have
gazillions of dollars I'd rather be on
the one with gazillions of dollars how
many of those people are on the platform
is it is a function of how much market
share that particular platform is
captured of my ideal who next we have
what's my ability to grow on the
platform some platforms are really easy
to grow some platforms are really hard
to grow the next one is the depth
because I don't want people to just
recognize my face although that is good
but I would much rather have them have a
good relationship with me where I can
provide tons of value which then
increases the likelihood of them
converting and then finally I'm going to
give you the results that I have now
underneath of depth I'll also give you a
little bit more intrinsic stats like
average view duration average percentage
viewed so you can look at your own stats
and kind of have that as a benchmark so
let's start with who I looked at Pew
research to see which percentage of
platforms have $100,000 families or
higher and how many of them are on that
platform want to know what it is for Tik
Tok it's
27% all right so 27% of families so
almost one out three out of four are not
on Tik Tok who make over $100,000 a year
that was surprising to me but when you
hear some of the rest of the stats it
will become less surprising the next
question is how many do we have here and
so this is a function of market share
within the United States which on Tik
Tok is 33% now we're like Okay so we've
got a lowish amount of people who make
money there's 33% market share across
the us at least now let's talk about
growth now on Tik Tok growth is one of
the highest and best components of Tik
Tok as in it's one of the easiest ones
to grow but I will say that in recent
history it's become harder and harder to
grow and because of the way that they've
changed the algorithm what we've noticed
is that shorts on one platform NE don't
necessarily work on Tik Tok anymore and
so now it's platform specific something
that works on Facebook reals might not
work on Instagram reals that might not
work on YouTube shorts which might not
work on Tik Tok and so it's actually
becoming more and more fragmented which
is why this video is so important so you
put your attention where it matters most
with all that being said Tik Tok still
ranks high among the Platforms in terms
of discoverability and your ability to
grow from zero meaning it favors newer
creators now it still may be hard but it
still favors people equally versus other
platforms where they still skew towards
larger creators so when it comes to
depth our next marker it's about how
much time are they going to actually
spend per unit of content that we put
out so Tik Tok ranks really low here so
on the low side you get something like
five seconds to 20 seconds at least
these are the statistics that we have on
the low to high side in terms of
duration per view now mind you that's
not a lot of time to provide a ton of
value especially it's just someone's
immediately scrolling immediately
scrolling and if you absolutely murder
it and you get 25 seconds from them I
think the main benefit you get is that
they just recognize your face I can
almost tell whenever I get recognized in
public when someone is a Tik Tok viewer
because they're like you're that guy I
don't know your name but yeah I see you
right versus people on like YouTube are
like dude you've changed my life you've
made me so much money you're the best I
know your name I bought your book it's
completely different Avatar in terms of
the experience so then we have
conversion now Tik Tok has two things
that are kind of interesting that you
might not know so number one jenzy
prefers Instagram DMS to Tik Tok DMS and
so in terms of your ability to convert
people from Tik Tok it actually tends to
be significantly lower now for very low
ticket things things like Tik Tok shop
are coming out are having massive
adoption which is encouraging but if
you're selling any kind of services
which 78% of businesses are this one's
kind of tough and so I'm going to put
this as low and to be clear Tik Tok a
couple years ago was amazing for new
creators because it was the first one
that had short videos which is easier
for someone to get into it's much harder
to write make a 20 minute high
production nice valuable piece of
content for YouTube versus a 15-second
short that you can put on Tik Tok but
then the other platforms caught on and
you got YouTube shorts Instagram reels
the Facebook reels uh and all the other
platforms that have short LinkedIn has
shorts now like they're all over the
place and so let's get to the results
and this is where it gets really crazy
and so I have almost 900,000 followers
on Tik Tok at the point of this video
and the amount of traffic that I get
from my Tik Tok despite being about a
tenth of my follower account is only
2.5% of all of the traffic that goes to
my page which I've tracked on our CRM
and so it basically has 1/4 the
effectiveness per unit compared to the
other platforms which means that some
other platforms are disproportionately
making up the volume and the whole
reason I wanted to collect all this data
for me was because there was a business
owner who was a winner of the school
games so school.com games and when he
came out he was like yeah it's really
weird I have 800,000 on Tik Tok and I
have 200,000 on Instagram but 90% of my
Revenue comes from Instagram and I
thought about that and I was like wait a
second so think about this the amount of
time that he spends on Tik Tok could he
spend all of that time on Instagram and
get 10% more to make up for all of it
and the answer is probably yes and so
that totally changed my perspective in
terms of thinking wait a second we want
to grow everywhere but there's
definitely some platforms where we get
higher returns for our Avatar which is
business owners and so for you and your
avatar looking at the stats should give
you where you should put your time so
you can make the most money especially
if you're on a budget and you can't do
10 platforms right you can maybe just do
one or two you should do the ones that
make you the most and by the way if you
want to check out one of our workshops
you can go to acquisition. comom we'd
love to talk to you it's for business
owners only so if you don't have a
business go to school.com and we can H
you star one with all this taken into
consideration what am I doing with my
Tik Tok
strategy I am rating it an f and it's
something that I'm not putting a ton of
time and attention into because there
are other platforms that are making me
way more per unit of time money and
effort I'm putting in and one more thing
that my team just told me about Tik Tok
real quick is that the average session
length of someone going from tiktop to
acquisition. my website is 8 seconds now
you'll see some of the ones later are
way higher so the next platform is the
tubes which if you're watching this on
YouTube then this is for you so we're
going to cover the same metrics as
before and we're going to start with who
what percentage of families over 100k
are here survey says eight
89% so take that in consideration versus
Tik Tok which was much much lower than
that all right people who have money are
on YouTube the next thing is what
percentage of the United States is on
here 83% all right so you've got a huge
percentage of the people who are making
the most money on the platform and so
growth for this platform really comes
down to how discoverable is your content
on the platform and to give you context
for me at least 80% of my traffic comes
from the suggested or browsed features
meaning you know more than 3/4 of the
people that come and watch my stuff
maybe you right now actually weren't
coming because you were a subscriber but
because the algorithm said you might
like this video and so for me I rate
this as high now the next question is
Okay so we've got the right people we
can grow on this platform these are all
pluses so the next thing is well how
much time are these people actually
spending with you so you can really
provide value well for us our average
view duration per video across all
channels is over 8 and 1/2 minutes all
right so it's 8 and 1/2 minutes now
compare that to the 5 to 20 seconds that
we're getting on Tik Tok I mean we're
talking 20 times I need to do the math
but it's a lot a lot more uh time is
spent here versus others and so this
allows you to develop a more realistic a
deeper realer relationship with your
audience because you can actually give
them value that they can do stuff with
if we want to do a quick Apples to
Apples with Tik Tok obviously YouTube
has shorts so let me tell you something
interesting about this the average
YouTube short that we have has a 33
second average view duration remember 5
to 20 on Tik Tok we're more than twice
that over here on YouTube now how does
this actually translate to what we care
about which is conversion when we talk
about the convertibility of YouTube is
actually one of the lower ones but
there's a massive caveat here which is
that you can't D I can't DM you if
you're a subscriber there's no real
story that I can post and immediately
see it the closest thing is the
community tab that you can do which by
the way murders so if you do have a
YouTube channel highly recommend doing
ctas on the community tab sporadically
when it makes sense and so for here I
would rate this low to medium the the
community tab kind of brings it up a
little bit but by and large it's very
hard for people to immediately convert
they basically have to click a link
somewhere else and if you put it in the
video it does kill your viation so it's
like if you're going to say something
you just got to make it short make sure
that it's not too big of an ask from the
audience and then you can put links in
the description which by the way if you
look at our description you can just
look you want to put it above the fold
so you want to have to be the first
thing that somebody sees uh before they
even click see more is where you want to
drive them you can also Pro tip put the
first comment that you have in the
comment section just pin that comment so
that gives you two different places and
third inside the video where you can
drive traffic this is just something
that I've learned over time but still
that's a lot of effort and it's not like
hey respond to my Instagram story
foreshadowing uh and we can take we can
start a conversation immediately on the
platform and to give context on this
little Community post thing I was saying
my community post over the last 30 days
had 2 and a half million impressions and
to get put that in context my short
videos got about 18 million impressions
so it's not it's not nothing it is it is
relatively significant especially when
you can load it with some sort of call
to action in there but no matter what
you pretty much have to take people off
the platform in order to converse with
them and potentially convert them now
let's talk about results cuz all this
stuff is conjecture let's get to the
Brass tax which is here's the crazy
thing drum roll
28.6% of our traffic comes from YouTube
all right so a massive amount but
there's another caveat that I want to
put on top of this our YouTube traffic
converts at three to four times every
other platform so when people these
clicks that go here are worth a ton and
so the actual percentage of the contacts
that we create people who want to become
portfolio companies business owners that
want to scale and go to acquisition.
almost 60% of those contacts actually
come from YouTube originally and
remember that little 8sec average that
Tik Tok gave us in terms of how long
people even spend on the page want to
guess what it is for YouTube It's 91
seconds it's a minute and a half so
we're talking 10x the amount of time
that people actually spending on page
all right so you're taking somebody who
has high intention that you've delivered
value to they actually remember your
name and you can actually start a
meaningful conversation to help them in
a more deep way VIA Commerce selling
stuff whatever so one of the things that
actually got me on YouTube originally
one of the last pieces of content that I
consumed before I was like you know what
I'm going to start creating was I heard
this guy who had a 20-some question
application and he was on a podcast and
he said I get about 3,000 applications a
month and I looked at his YouTube
channel and he had like 300,000
subscribers and I was like holy cow
because at this point all I had done was
paid ads and so I was like 3,000 inbound
warm applications I was like my God if I
had that kind of volume I'd be able to
do so much with that and so when I saw
the 300,000 and I saw that that
translated into 3,000 applications a
month I was like there's something here
and I'm going to try and figure it out
and so if you are getting started listen
I have a massive team but I didn't start
that way so I had one guy who I stayed
committed to posting three videos a week
and if you look at the very earliest
videos on my channel it's me with a
webcam at my desk just talking about
business stuff as it came up throughout
the day and so I would encourage you to
just start and then all you have to do
is every month or every week look back
at the three videos you made the week
before and just try and improve one
thing and if you just stick that what
happens is you create this checklist
over time that becomes this Mondo
checklist of what ultimately creates an
exceptional video that performs I
remember when I got so excited when we
had my first thousand view video in 24
hours and I was like dude can you
believe like there's going to be a time
where we're going get 10,000 views in a
day and now we do 100,000 views in our
first day and so the the the levels just
keep going and going and going as you
grow in skill and if you're going to
obsess about something these are the two
things I would obsess on number one is
the thumbnail one of my last two videos
was no BS advice on how to get rich in
10 years and we split test nine
different thumbnails and so thing one is
the thumbnail matters a lot thing two is
the first 8 Seconds of your video you
want to be done talking about what the
video is going to be about and start and
this is something that when I see you
know a beginner video I watch and it's
like 2 minutes before they actually
start the video you've already lost
everyone and so you're going to lose
most people in the first 30 seconds and
so you want to crush the intro so they
know exact it's exactly what you
promised in the thumb and headline and
then you get to the meet as fast as
possible and this video right here we
did eight different takes of the intro
where I slow worked from 30 seconds down
to 8 and then that's what became the
intro that you saw before seeing this
moment right now with all that being
said the YouTube gets the highest praise
in the internet uh ecosystem Jesus and
gets the S tier ranking because this is
where I'm doubling down and continuing
to pour more and more resource resources
because this is where I'm getting the
best returns next up we have the artist
forly known as Twitter currently known
as the X Factor first up we've got who's
on this platform so X has 29% of people
over $100,000 in household income are on
X so about the same as Tik Tok actually
a little bit higher the next question is
how many of these people right what
percentage of the population in the
United States is on X and so here this
is where it's a little bit lower so Tik
tok's got them they're at 33 versus 22
on X now let's talk about growth growth
for X it's one of the most viral
platforms because the share button is
the easiest button on X and Twitter and
this is fundamentally what allowed
people to organically grow on Twitter to
begin with but it is a platform that you
have to be really really good at words
and it takes a very long time to do that
but the advantage is that you can
actually tweet a sentence or a word or
an image or a meme and so there's a lot
of things that are native to the
platform and Elon continues to put more
and more stuff on there to make it more
more viral and just continue to improve
it overall and after being stagnant for
years Twitter's actually back on a
growth curve right now but here's an
interesting tibit for X users it's a
little bit more of a silo but the people
who are on X tend to be really hardcore
and so the average xuser spends 34
minutes per day on the platform which is
about half of some of the other
platforms but still not bad at all uh
comparatively the next one's real quick
depth we don't have stats because
there's no real average view duration uh
for Twitter but the easiest thing that I
look at for this is how you know how
many comments how how engaged people are
I don't have particular stats on it but
with that being said let's move on to
conversion which is what matters now
Twitter is interesting there's lots of
people that have 1,000 person followings
8,000 person followings and make
multiple millions of dollars a year on
Twitter because they're super niched
down in terms of the types of topics
they talk about in fact there was a
business that came here the other day
who is an a cro marketing agency that
specialized in e-commerce companies
doing over $10 million a year so talk
about like a niche of a niche of a niche
of a niche and he was doing 5 million a
year from his 8,000 person Twitter
following and all he did was have
indepth threads where he would just say
here's the split test that one here's
another split test that one and the
entire thing of his bio was if you want
a call click my calendar link and book a
call and he told me that he was getting
8 to 12 calls a day with unbelievably
qualified prospects and so one you have
to go off platform but you have this
link that's right there and immediately
visible the second thing on Twitter is
you can DM and so many people DM on
Twitter all the time and so people who
are on that platform are very accustomed
to it and the amount of access that you
get on Twitter SLX is kind of
unbelievable like you've got superstars
on there who will reply to DMS it's nuts
first thing you don't want to do if
you're just dming people on Twitter is
just DM them with an ask the amount of
people that have here is like hey can we
hop on a call
no no we can't thanks for the ass though
um I think Compliments are a great way
to start like Hey I Love This Thread
don't just say hey I love your stuff
point to a specific thread that you like
and then explain why and if someone says
thank you then you can respond
afterwards if someone doesn't say thank
you to a compliment then they're
probably not going to engage anyways and
so I would just start with some like
what is valuable to somebody is just
telling them they did a good job so I
rate this a high on the convertibility
of the audience now what does that
actually translate into us for results
so before I give you the stats on this I
want to give you a little bit of context
the reason I like X so much is that X is
actually my hub for Content so what I
mean is I consume X more than any other
platform personally and I on the Fly
create on X so 100% of the tweets that
are on X are me in the moment just
tweeting them out I heard something on a
meeting someone said something and I
think of a py way to say it and then I
shoot it out right now the thing is is
that X generates a little bit of results
and I'll explain what it is in a moment
but what it does do is it actually feeds
all the other platforms because the
captions on my Instagram are tweets from
here and the long form stuff that we put
on LinkedIn are just multiple tweets put
together and reformatted and so if you
ever see written word from Alex Heros on
any platform they are words that I wrote
I have no ghost writers I do have people
who assemble the words that I have and
then put them in a new order or group
them together but that's how I've been
able to scale my voice without ever
being like Oh that's really cringe so
your ability to repurpose all the stuff
you put on X is super high our
percentage of traffic that we get to our
site is 6.12% % and if you look at how
many people I have on Twitter it's about
6% of my total subscribers and so it's
about 1 to one in terms of the ratio
like it's pulling its weight in terms of
conversion even though this is a short
form platform compared to Tik Tok the
average session duration on my site from
someone from X is still four times
higher than Tik Tok so it's over 30
something seconds is what people do from
X on my site and for that reason I give
X
an a rating for me cuz the main thing is
is I'm not going to stop going on X we
don't really have a lot of Team
dedicated to X it's pretty much just me
and my team takes what I put there and
then sprays it everywhere else and so
this is for me incredibly valuable y'all
thought I was going to put it on S I
know uh but no this isn't a tier for me
I mean if I had to pick YouTube or X I
would do YouTube but X is the Wellspring
of everything else that I make which
leads us to the in of Link the link
magic the Professional Network where all
people are serious but no one really is
and let's break down how much money this
platform actually makes and I think it
will it will surprise you and I have
changed my view on LinkedIn who's on
LinkedIn now this one may surprise you
53% of households over
$100,000 are on LinkedIn so this is
double Tik Tok like we were talking
about earlier now the next question is
how many people in the United States are
on LinkedIn and this one was kind of
surprising to me it was 30% so I
actually thought it'd be way lower than
that because I figured no one uses
LinkedIn but it turns out a lot of
people use LinkedIn just not as much as
you'd think in terms of per day and so
the average amount of time spent on
LinkedIn per day per LinkedIn users is
about 7 minutes so way lower than a lot
of the other platforms so let's talk
about growth so growth for me and growth
for you should probably be incredibly
important because if the point of
advertising is to let people know about
your stuff you want platforms that let
way more people than already know about
you know about your stuff and so I give
LinkedIn a medium to high and I'll
explain why so LinkedIn is super
sharable and very connection driven and
so the part that I would say is high
about it is that there's a lot of people
who share on LinkedIn it's very common
to share stuff it's kind of like a
sharing culture and when you create high
value stuff people want the association
with that value and then they share
public because it makes them look like
they've got you know they thought
leaders now the flip side is the reason
that I I I still have this medium anchor
is that because it's connection driven
so think about it like a hinge so if you
have 10 people a lot of your posts will
get shown to people who are friends with
your connections right so it's like so
and so it's friends with so and so who
made this post right and so in the
beginning it can be harder for you to
get started because you might have a
only a few connections and so let me
give you a tip on this right now
wherever you went to high school
wherever you went to college if you went
to college wherever you work all of
these places are customary to have
LinkedIn profiles and by the way I would
strongly encourage you to at least put
one up there that looks like you exist
because from a professional setting I'll
tell you some of the big benefits that I
get that are not on this list that have
been worth it for me but you can get
your first 500 connections and the nice
thing with LinkedIn is they just say 500
plus so it's not like you have to think
like oh my God I need millions and
millions of people like you max out your
personal connections at 500 so it's very
you can do that with a high school class
like it's not hard to get going so let's
talk about depth real quick because
there's no average duration we have no
real stats on that so let's get on to
the drum roll of conversion now LinkedIn
so think about think about like you know
Tik Tock is like a a bomb or like a
sprinkler right LinkedIn is like you've
got a hose with a a laser pointer on it
and you can shoot whoever you want with
it all right and so the conversion
ability on LinkedIn is extremely high
all right and I'm I'm going to talk
about this in a couple couple couple
different vectors so number one is it's
very high because there's a ton of
sophisticated tools LinkedIn is built
for outbound meaning you can get
incredibly targeted with your search
ability criteria for prospects and so if
you want to find hedge fund managers who
are in this state and above this age you
can do that and so LinkedIn has
something called sales navigator that
you can use 40% of B2B marketers say
that this is their primary channel for
getting customers so like do not sleep
on the ability now mind you LinkedIn ads
shaky some people make them work uh
LinkedIn content over overall will help
you convert when you do DMS but this is
an outbound monster all right and
relative to the following count that you
have on LinkedIn your ability to make
money is probably the highest so you can
have the tiniest following and make the
most money on LinkedIn because of how
targeted you can be with your Outreach
and how easy it is to message someone
who engages with your content and before
I move on to results I want to give you
a little hack here for the growth one of
the biggest growth methods right now in
LinkedIn is getting large accounts to
comment on your stuff and so if a large
account comments on your thing it gets
shown to all of their following and so
it's a massive leverage Point like think
about a comment almost as a collab and
so you want to do whatever you can to
attract those bigger accounts and I'll
tell you an easy hack for this write
about them talk about how great this
person is or how great a particular
piece of content they made is like
actually write something significant and
you have a high likelihood that they
will say like hey thanks this was
awesome and the longer their response is
the more engagement draws to you like
there was a guy that U made a comment uh
made a post the other day and I
commented on it and he had a smallish
following and that post got I think like
50 times his average in terms of likes
and comments after that because I have a
large following on LinkedIn and so he
got to leverage basically the entirety
of my Audience by just making a piece of
content that I found relevant so drum
roll for the results and this will
surprise you over 9% plus of my traffic
to my site comes from LinkedIn and the
average session duration of these people
is over 40 seconds all right so it's
higher than every other
platform besides YouTube all right so
really strong intent from these people
now let me give you the Thousand IQ move
that is the reason that I like LinkedIn
a lot so for me we have a portfolio of
companies at acquisition. comom right
now it's just under 10 companies that do
uh over $250 million a year in revenue
and so we constantly are recruiting
highlevel talent for our portfolio
companies and for our holding company to
acquisition and so the biggest unspoken
Roi that I get from LinkedIn and that
Lila gets from LinkedIn is that our DMS
are about recruiting so we can go
directly head hunt some of the best
people in the world and because we have
followings because they can look at the
stuff we put out there the response
rates that we get are higher than any
other platform for talent and so if you
want to get really amazing people
LinkedIn is going to be the big lever
that you can use to grow your business
by just getting the smartest people on
your team so with all that being said
we've got a lot of people with money
we've got decent growth we've got high
conversion ability High intent and just
to give you context on this 9% it's
about twice its weight based on the
percentage of followers that I have on
LinkedIn so we get way more per follower
than like Tik talkk where I get 1/4th
the amount of followers that actually
translate into results so where does
LinkedIn go
survey
says boom B tier and main reason here is
that uh I don't think that it can
generate as much at least for me but it
is like I would put it like almost
between the two but in terms of where
I'm putting my actual resources we use a
lot of my ex content on LinkedIn and
it's worked exceptionally well and so
we're probably like it's going to I'm
basically continuing to invest the same
amount that I have been investing in
LinkedIn next up we've got the Graham
the myth the legend Instagram
itself champion of children father to
the fatherless and uh money maker to
people who shake their booties so that
being said I'm a B2B guy I Ser as
business owner so how does Instagram
measure up for me again the results may
surprise you like they did for me so
number one what percentage of people
over 100k are on here 54% all right so a
really monster percentage the second
highest that we've had so far across all
platforms only second to YouTube next
next how many people in the United
States are on Zam all right which is
47% again the second highest that we've
come to so far so pretty promising up
top now let's talk about growth growth
because of the Advent of re right now is
high all right you can if you are
formatting your stuff correctly get
viral growth and they're putting more
and more to try and favor new Creator so
if you look at a guy named moseri he's
the head of Instagram uh i' recommend
following him no association just has a
lot of stuff like from the horse's mouth
of what they're doing in the algorithm
what they want to favor and I'll tell
you a fun fact that he shared with me
personally not really it was on on his
Instagram um is that a lot of people
think that Instagram's favoring video
and he said no people favor video and so
that's what gets shared the most it's
not that we did anything to the
algorithm it's just people just prefer
to engage in videos and the big thing
that they care about is shares they want
to see how many people take your video
and then immediately send send it to
friends and especially if you send it
off platform so if you copy the link and
then text it that's what gets more
people to Instagram that's the Holy
Grail of what they want for the bad news
so the depth on Instagram is lower now
it's not as low as Tik Tok but for us
it's 12 to 20% uh sorry 12 to 20 seconds
now I'm going to give you a little bit
of context on this number so I
personally tend to do a lot of tweet
reels and my tweet reels are like 3
seconds or 5 Seconds long so no one can
even watch longer than that and so that
skews my data lower and so if we had the
if we wanted to take the time to like
look at every single video that's not a
tweet real and then par the data out we
could probably figure it out but I'll
bet you that it's significantly higher
than this based on some of these down
funnel metrics so people see the Tweet
RS they share them that's how some of my
growth comes but a lot of the depth for
me comes from alternating between these
kind of higher top of funnel if you will
uh tweet based uh videos versus the kind
of in-depth uh me talking to business
owner me at a Q&A or whatever this is
something that we learned the hard way
so Instagram is unlike Tik Tok in terms
of the fact that they penalize you for
posting too much and so we've tried you
know eight a day six a day four a day
and so we found our sweet spot at two
sessions per day so one in the morning
one in the evening and we kind of spread
them out now Tik Tok for example we post
way more frequently and as you see I'm
going to be divesting some of my
attention there but you don't get
penalized ized same as X you don't get
penalized for tweeting more you don't
get penalized for posting more Tik toks
at the moment and so for us we really
spend more time curating the one to two
things that we put out per day on here
because they're the only shots we've got
so let's talk about your ability to
convert your audience on Instagram so
this one I would say honestly is
probably only second to LinkedIn in
terms of your convertibility LinkedIn
has other things that make it worse than
Instagram some of the other stats I
shared but in terms of your ability to
convert on Instagram it's so good so the
only thing you can't do is get laser
targeted the way you can with sales
Navigator whoa uh but what you can do is
you've got stories where you can do ctas
you can do swipe UPS people can click
links you can link it with uh tools like
mini chat where if someone DMS you a
certain word or comments a certain word
it begins a conversation with them and
so you can do all of your Commerce
directly on Instagram they also have
Instagram shop like they have really and
they're continuing to invest in this to
make this such a high convert platform
and the story that I told the very
beginning a guy who had 800,000 on Tik
Tok and 200,000 on Instagram he was
getting 90% of his revenue from
Instagram I was like I need to make a
video on this because I need to look at
our data to see if we need to reallocate
our own resources to make the most money
and so here's a really important point
with conversion a lot of people chase
views and so like if you go up to
strangers on the street and slap them
and run away you're going to get a ton
of views because it's crazy viral stuff
but you're not going to get the right
types of views from the right who unless
you sell how to sell you know how to
slap strangers in public and not get hit
back right but unless that's what you
sell that's probably going to be
relevant content for you and so if
you're an educator you're a business
owner which most of us are Educators not
entertainers then what you're going to
want to make sure that you're making
your content is about the stuff you sell
and about the problems that your avatar
or ideal Avatar suffers from and how you
can help solve them all right and so
there's a there's a nutritional
dietitian who I met who had 5,800
followers on Instagram she do a million
dollars a year and with a couple tweaks
that I walk through with her I think
she'll do three to 5 million just from
5800 followers and her content here's
the crazy part the highest piece of
content that I could find when I
scrolled had 19 likes but she was making
10 sales a day on average for her $39 to
$99 thing and then she would manually
email every person who bought the thing
and say hey want to buy my more
expensive thing and she was doing almost
$100,000 a month just from that simple
system and you know what her really
Niche was she talked about how to build
insurance companies more profitably all
of her content was like hey here's Aetna
and how you can build them way more than
you currently are as a registered
dietitian so like a niche of a niche of
an Niche and me personally I look at a
lot of gym equipment it's something that
I'm really interested I'm a hobbyist if
you want to call it that and so a lot of
metal fabricators you might be surprised
are very terrible marketers and so a lot
of them have like five likes 20 likes on
their post but guess who sees them me
cuz that's what Instagram knows I love
if they put a new machine that I haven't
seen I'm clicking on it and so I would
encourage you don't worry about the
likes worry about who the likes are
coming from and one of the cool things
with Instagram because of all the
different ways you can convert on there
is that you can always be seen as giving
and you can convert in private and so
you don't even need to make asks
publicly if you just say hey DM me this
or hey I want to send you this thing
then you can start the conversation and
you can do the Commerce on the
conversation rather than in public so
give in public sell in private and this
enables you to do both and this may be
the stat that blows your mind the most
the amount of traffic that goes to my
site from Instagram is
48% 48% of my acquisition. comom traffic
comes from Instagram now I'll give you a
little caveat here because this will be
important is that by absolute amounts
Instagram sends more traffic to
acquisition. comom than YouTube does
you're like huh well that's interesting
now in terms of session length remember
this was 91 this one is 28 seconds in
session length so it is shorter now mind
you a lot of the content here is shorter
so it kind of makes sense that people
would follow their same kind of
consumption pattern when they click over
and so here's the the down fact about
Instagram from this is that when they go
to my site people on Instagram convert
significantly less than the people on
YouTube but they convert about the same
as the other platforms tldr tons of
traffic coming from Instagram conversion
about the same and for that reason I
rank the Graham in let's see if I don't
tear this damn page off here we go I
rank this as an S tier is it as an S
tier is that what the Gen Z kids say
these days it is an S tier it's the top
guy it's very good I put both of these
as my my two top dogs that we're
investing the same or more resources
going into the next year next up we have
the book of faces the man the myth
himself smashbook original this one is
actually one that I've changed my mind
on and so before I dive into these stats
on Facebook I had to restart my account
because and I'll tell you what I made as
a mistake so years and years ago I was a
new entrepreneur and someone told me uh
just go run ads in Thailand because you
get clicks for like a penny and you can
get followers for like 10 cents a piece
and so I ran ads to get my Facebook
following to 70,000 so I looked legit
now here's the problem with that is that
Facebook then serves content that I have
this is back in the day to people who
were the people who liked my page
unsurprisingly and it turns out people
who don't speak English and are just
randomly selected from Thailand are not
that interested in business content and
so it basically prevented me from
growing my account when I actually
wanted to go legit and make valuable
content this is years and years later
but I still have my original profile and
so we had to restart my Facebook profile
just in this last year and so for those
of you were like man he's he's got all
these F I started at zero this year all
right so and like we were like hey we
got a th000 views on a video and we
started all over again so like don't be
afraid of that it's just part of the
game everyone starts at zero so let's
rock the stats real quick so of people
over 100k how many of them on here
68% all right so second only to zit tube
how many of people in America now this
is a wild one it's also 68% of America
is on Facebook now known as meta I
thought both are meta I'm confused you
get the idea now let's talk about growth
all right because this is where it
matters all right got it we got a bunch
of the people that we want on there a
lot of the United States is on there
because it's an older platform how about
growth now because now there was a
moment for a few years where Facebook
was very tough to grow on so it was like
organic on Facebook crushed and then all
of a sudden it stopped crushing and they
were like you have to use our ads
platform if you want get any views and
basically Facebook organic like died and
then they resurrected it again when
reals came out and they started making
reals for Facebook and so now growth on
Facebook I would say is high again all
right if you make stuff that's platform
specific again I've noticed we have
noticed that stuff that performs really
well on Instagram doesn't necessarily
perform well on Facebook and stuff
shorts on Tik Tok don't necessarily
perform well here so each platform is
getting more and more you know separated
in terms of what performs well so with
this one we weren't able to pull our our
average view per but I would say that
it's high because the average session
length for us is 53 seconds on our site
from people who come from Facebook which
means that of all the ones so I'm going
to spoil this one for you uh of all the
platforms it is the second highest
session length on our site which has a
higher translation over to contacts and
downstream things like money all right
now let's talk conversion so the
convertibility on Facebook I would say
is high not as high as Instagram but
High because a lot of the same features
have been carried over one is you've got
Facebook Stories and people can respond
to your stories you can DM on Facebook
it links with tools like many chat where
you can do automation on Facebook and so
you have a lot of different ways that
you can convert people and it's a
platform where many many many many
people have profiles and get
notifications when they get messages so
we will rate this as I'm going to say a
high medium to high uh like super high
medium extra medium ish medium if you
will and so let's talk about results
because this is what matters most to
everybody here right and so this one is
also fascinating so 3.8% of our traffic
comes from Facebook now I only have like
150,000 followers on Facebook so for me
that's the smallest of all the accounts
I'm going to talk about today but this
is more than Tik Tok which has almost
900,000 so my
150,000 followers on Facebook generate
more than almost double the amount that
my Tik Tok does with one6 the amount of
people who are actually following so you
look at the relative difference it's one
and a half times more conversion on 1
16th so it's 9x the potency so you
catching on with this here you're like
wait a second you spent all this time
here and in just a few months here you
were able to get way more people to your
site to ultimately convert later yeah
and so if you're like should I start a
Tik Tok or should I make more content on
Facebook
well I'll let you use your second brain
cell and figure that one out for
yourself and so one of the cool Parts
about Facebook is it's kind of like a a
hybrid between LinkedIn and Instagram
because you can do long form text posts
and like very long thread based stuff
you can do pictures and you can do video
on there and so it's a platform that's
been really adaptable in terms of the
amount of different types of content
that you can create and I see that as a
big plus because Facebook's almost like
the whatever you want to make they'll
support you in making it with the
exception of Maybe audio and with that
being said I have now moved Facebook in
my life so before this it was below FTI
we weren't even making content on
Facebook at all but when we started
looking at these stats I was like oh
this is oh this is oh is oh H oh yeah
this is actually an a tier for me and
that may be surprising for you but this
is where I'm putting more of my
resources in the next year because of
all the things I just said and to be
clear before I made this video I it was
lower but when we looked at all the data
this is how I'm prioritizing my
resources and so if you're like man
which one should I should create on this
should inform you also if you want the
The Meta lesson here look at your data
so I just do what the data tells me to
do which is oh we get we have high
growth here we have high conversion we
have lots of people who have the money
uh who are on this platform it's one of
the oldest platforms they now have more
discoverability and so yeah I'm putting
more time into it and before before I
get into our double feature for this
next one uh I'm going to do some
honorable mentions at the end that I am
putting some resource SWS that I didn't
want to put on this list that I think
will be very valuable for you to at
least understand but more realistically
make money from so our double feature of
the day we've got zip podcast which is a
Spotify thing but uh it's still a
podcast cuz did you know that spotify's
podcast I know crazy and email and
you're like wait a second are these
social platforms yes and no and that's
why I'm going to talk about at the same
time cuz I actually think that these two
platforms are more similar than they are
different and so the big reason is all
of this stuff is kind of your growth
mechanisms and I'm already doing a
little foreshadowing on our growth one
here but like your email list for
example is not going to just like Sprout
Sprout babies and have more emails that
get made right if you write a banger
email you're probably not going to
really grow the list but if you have a
banger piece of content on these
platforms you might absolutely grow your
following which then goes to your site
which then into your list and so the
same happens with podcasts right podcast
and email are both what I would consider
long-term nurture you're basically
putting your audience into a bucket so
that you can consistently add value to
them now here's the interesting thing
with both these this is considered owned
media meaning you can directly email
anybody who gives you their email
address obviously people have crms and
things like that so you can blast email
but you're still guaranteed to reach the
email that they gave you uh Spotify and
uh Apple podcast and whatnot people only
listen to this is this is so important
people usually only listen to three to
five podcasts and so think about your
Instagram for example if you look at the
number of people you follow you might
follow 500 you might follow a th000 you
might follow 3,000 people on your
Instagram and so all 3,000 of those
accounts are competing for your scroll
every time you log in but if you get on
someone's
listener
followership
earballs you are only competing against
three for other people and so as long as
you continue to consistently deliver you
will basically be able to keep that
person over the Long Haul now let's talk
about some stats and then we'll get into
the money on the people who got money
we've got 54% now the stat that we found
here was 75 we couldn't find uh the stat
for 100k that's all right 54% of people
over 75k listen to podcasts and 96% now
this might be unsurprising of people
whoever over1 who make over $100,000 a
year are on email now let's look at
America so 92 % of Americans use email
I'm like what are the other 8% I want to
be in the 8% uh there but uh 64% of
Americans uh are using podcast or audio
in some format which is actually way
higher than I thought this was going to
be I thought it was still like more of a
you know kids Tech whatever but no a lot
of people listen to podcast I thought
more people would be on radio let's talk
about the sad news for both of these
your ability to grow a podcast is really
low it's very very hard to grow a
podcast same as growing an email list
now to be clear these things paired with
these things very valuable but these
things on their own the vast majority of
like big podcasters what do you think
they also have big ass YouTubes so they
take their podcast they put them on
YouTube and then they grow now in the
very very very early days when like six
people were having podcasts there was
growth on the platforms but now there
are so many uh podcasts that are out
there it's very hard Now podcast
relative to the amount of people who are
on Instagram I think it's like 6 million
podcasts and there's I don't know two
billion people on Instagram who are
quote creators whatever and so you're
still competing against a much smaller
uh slice of creators but the card that
someone's looking at they only got three
to five and so there is fierce
competition here now emails lots of
people are spamming people's inboxes and
so you have to be something that people
want to click on and read so that brings
us to the depth now both of these are
going to be off the charts compared to
everything else so the depth on podcast
dude check this out 20 minutes is the
average for us in terms of listen
duration for people on podcast I mean it
blows everything out of the water I mean
the the closest is YouTube at 8 and a
half now emails we don't have a depth
because I can't say like how long it
some to read but for us we have about
40% plus open rates on our emails and so
I see that as like okay they're engaged
they are at least clicking and reading
the stuff that we sent out which is very
sporadic because I need to work on that
uh that being said let's talk about
conversion so we've got these two we got
lots of people with money low ability to
grow really deep which you know what
that's going to mean is that these guys
are plus plus they're high in terms of
your conversion I mean email is the
conversion platform of conversion
platforms so I'll give you a step if
you're not making at least 30% of your
revenue from email you're missing out
and if you're not emailing well and this
is this is me talking to myself too here
you're just losing so much money because
the thing is is that the return on email
is the highest across all platforms all
right so the average person gets 36 to1
return so if you have to spend money on
someone writing emails for you these are
basically free delivery like the only
real cost is the cost of delivering the
message and whatever CRM or sender you
have to pay for however many emails a
month you need to send and the person
who's actually writing the email if it's
not you that's it that's the only real
cost and you can absolutely write a
amazing copy make crazy offers there's
the least amount of Co compliance that
you have to deal with like if you get
your Facebook ad account shut down or
you get your Instagram you're not really
going to get your email taken down now
you could get a bad reputation with like
Gmail and then they stop putting you in
the main inbox that put you in
promotions but big picture as long as
you're doing things the right way you
can have exceptional results with email
in terms of converting an audience and
with podcasts I'll say this I put a plus
here I'll make it a I'll make it a plus
minus the amount of people that trust
the person that they listen to podcast
is through the roof all right so when
you make a recommendation the percentage
likely that your audience that listens
converts is very high but the actual
difficulty of converting on podcasts is
also High because most times people have
to take out their phone type in the
address or like it disrupts The
Experience most people are listening
they don't have their they're on their
they're on their they're listening to
their car radio CU they're listening to
their car or they you know the phone's
next to them or it's you know they're at
the gym and so they have to stop midet
and be like okay now I'm going to type
in this address and they'll go convert
or they have to remember to do it later
which they never will and so that's to
me a very big downside of this but it
still in my opinion allows you to just
get this huge amount of depth with an
audience so that when you do make ctas
everywhere else it increases the likely
they convert but let's talk about
results now for podcast I actually can't
give results because when people type it
in separately I can't know if they came
from anywhere but I know that podcasts
help us now emails is absolutely tracked
and I can tell you that those numbers
that we said uh are good now here's
where it gets
wild
133 seconds is the average session time
of someon on email on my site now here's
why this is exceptionally powerful we
already have their email so this isn't
me tring to convert them uh I already
have their contact info so this is when
I'm making a call to action saying hey
we just opened up a new date or two
dates for a scaling workshop at our
headquarters acquisition. comom in Vegas
if you're business doing over a million
bucks a year go there so by the way you
can go there acquisition. comom and just
hit the scale button if you're a
business owner if you're not a business
owner don't do that um but if you're
spending a minute you know 2 Minutes
Plus on there it means that you're
actually like engaging with what's on
the site deciding to book a call with
our team all right and so this is
monstrous and for us we're working on
sending more emails because honestly I'm
so particular about written word which
is why I've been so hesitant to send
emails to begin with you'd be surprised
right big author likes uh is very
particular about his words yeah that's
me and so like I said for Facebook there
are some things that this video is
changing about my behavior and so
definition of learning same condition
new behavior and so if you watch this
video and then it changes what you do as
a result of it than you have learned and
so for me taking this data I have
learned things and so let me tell you
where I'm prioritizing
jeez all right so where are these guys
going where are these guys going for me
this guy is staying in the b class all
right I do like the depth of it I hate
the fact that it can't it's really hard
to grow but I do think it longterm is
good for brand and things like that
email right here I'm putting on the same
level this is a tier the only reason
it's not s TI because you can't grow but
in terms of convertibility this is the
monster of convertibility it's LinkedIn
sales navigator on steroids it's the
people that already trust you the most
and you can consistently continue to
deliver messages to them whenever you
like as long as you continue to provide
value so I have four honorable mentions
that I'm not going to do the full Deep
dive on but I think are important and
the last one is the one that you will
not expect and has made a tremendous
amount of money for me that if you're
good you can crush on so the first three
are Pinterest Snapchat and twitch now
right now twitch has been favoring super
super long streams like all day long
streams like walking along with me
living Day in the Life whatever and
people are going nuts for it I it's been
tough for me because I do a lot of
meetings with uh portfolio companies and
I we share stuff that I can't really
talk about and so like it gets tough
It's actually why I haven't made many
Vlogs because it was so hard uh the in
and the out and if I'm working for hours
so I I haven't done it but if you have a
life or a workstyle that allows you to
do it I think twitch is a huge
opportunity now Snapchat has done an
exceptional job at Commerce and so the
average revenue per viewer on Snapchat I
think is one of the highest if not the
highest across all platforms and so it's
really big in uh Millennials but it's
coming at coming back fast with like gen
Z which is kind of interesting and so um
that's one that I've kind of have my eye
on I still haven't put it on my list of
where I'm going to invest resources into
I want to keep doing what we're doing
better but it's one to keep an eye on
now now Pinterest if you are in a
business that has anything that's very
visual I you should absolutely be on
Pinterest so I had an art dealer who
came here and she had 90% of her
business came from Pinterest and
Pinterest has the highest average
revenue per user all right so I think
it's 120,000 plus is the average it's
wild how many uh how much people who are
on Pinterest make and so like it tends
to be female skewed and so like think
about the arts and craft stuff think
about wines think about decoration home
decor those types of businesses if
you're in one of those Smash and highly
recommend putting resources there
because again you're not going to be
competing against a lot of people
because far fewer creators are on there
all right so what is my big
secret number four drum roll please well
I've actually been seating you with it
this whole time and know the books are
not a traffic Source it's actually
Amazon so if we think through the same
vectors we had earlier Amazon what
percentage of people who are over
100,000 on here all of them 300 million
Americans are on Prime are on paid
subscriptions absolutely absurd the most
successful product adoption in history
was Amazon Prime next is how many it's
the whole United States everybody's on
Amazon so for you to grow on Amazon you
absolutely can and so what a lot of
people don't know is that Amazon was
actually one of my earliest platforms
and so when I had only 10,000 followers
on Instagram and I had maybe 10,000
followers on YouTube I don't even think
I was making YouTubes yet I published
this book and so a lot of people think
that this book has the 26,000 five stars
that it has on Amazon because of the
following that we have and that's not
true this book sold more copies than I
had people on my email list all right so
talk about contacts versus customers now
Amazon has all of this traffic of all
these people who have money now are are
these people able to convert [__] you
they have a credit card on file and they
can buy in one click so Amazon is built
for Commerce it's also why twitch is one
of the things that there's some there's
big opportunities there now I'm going to
do a little caveat here if you are an
influencer or you would like to start
creating content I think that Amazon is
a sleeper and so let me walk you through
some math my book page converts at
30% all right so like if you had a 30%
optin you'd be like stoked no no no 30%
of people who View my book page buy a
book and to give you a relative
comparison here Shopify the average is
around 2% so it has a 15 time at least
for me 15 times higher conversion for me
versus Shopify because there's so much
trust innate to the
platform so if you are an Instagram
influencer or
Creator if you promote someone else's
stuff the commissions on Amazon I'm
pretty sure fixed about
10% but if you can convert 10 times more
people when you send them to Amazon than
you do when you send them to something
that you get 20 or 30% on that only
converts at 2% you're still going to
make more money and as an added bonus
when you promote stuff on Amazon in my
opinion it doesn't feel nearly as asky
if you're like hey I was reading this
really cool book I think you like it
I've got a link here people are like oh
he's he's always selling this stuff it's
like no you're just providing value from
products that you found and so I think
that the Amazon affiliate model is one
of the most under tapped for influencers
who are like I don't know what to sell
it's like dude sell the stuff you like
so like instead of trying to think of
products and things like that I think
the V1 is just like hey these flannels
are awesome I found them on Amazon and
here is the link right and so these
aren't on Amazon unfortunately but point
being I think this is one of the most
under tapped opportunities because
here's what's cool about this traffic
Source on top of all the things I just
said if you put CTA
inside of your content inside of your
books the stuff that you sell people can
go there and then find you and these are
people that I would never have otherwise
found all right so they found a book
that had a zillion five stars they
bought and read the book and then that
is how they discovered me and so my
growth here that I want to say is it's
incredible and also very difficult
because the only way that you can grow
on Amazon is having a good product but
if you do have a good product you can
put in the QR codes you can put ctas if
it's education based like media like
books uh if you have physical products
on Amazon you can put the the little QR
codes in there but this is another huge
stream of people finding out about your
stuff who otherwise wouldn't have now
results these books sell almost a
thousand books a day on Amazon which is
absurd a lot of people are really
excited to get a th000 email contacts a
day we get 1,000 customers a day from
the books and to be clear this is not I
make my money but these actually have
become a much bigger Revenue stream than
I expected given it's just you know it's
$30 book and also by the way guys you
can you can get it for free on my
podcast both of these are in audio
format for free on my podcast you can
search my name this one's a sleeper and
if you are good it's worth putting some
of your best stuff up there even if you
put it free somewhere else because I see
it as a traffic source and the more
money you make Amazon the more they push
it if you enjoy this video and you're
trying to grow your personal brand I I
have a deep dive with full slides and
presentation on how branding really
works today to make money check it out